the conspiracy theories continue from
the right Lara Trump is the latest who
suggests that maybe it was Barack Obama
yes who planted the classified documents
in Joe Biden's garage who is pulling the
strings that's saying all right now Joe
Biden is done he served his purpose
there is no end there is no bottom there
is no limit to what these people will
say of course it's completely absurd but
it is all being done to try to take
attention away from the fact that it is
Donald Trump who has the real classified
documents problem I've said investigate
both of them look into what Joe Biden
did if he did something wrong he should
be investigated and there should be
consequences but just because Biden's
being investigated doesn't mean Trump is
now Vindicated in any way just be if
you're accused of murder and then
someone else is accused of murder you
can't say well now that they're accused
of murder my investigation is over
that's not the way that criminality
works